pour l'instant je vous propose deux
poursuivre cette page culture avec la
ville de Montigny qui lance qui a
dévoilé sa prochaine saison culturelle
pour en parler avec nous José Cachin le
maire adjoint à la Culture de la Ville
José Cachan cette saison culturelle
s'annonce riche on a du théâtre de
l'humour et des concerts exactement tout
est dit on est ravi
moi je suis toujours très fier de porter
un petit peu cette saison culturelle
parce que le sourire des gens est
fondamental les retrouver c'est
essentiel aussi on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés c'est deux trois dernières
années mais on s'est rendu compte que
aujourd'hui les gens agissent
différemment en matière de d'achat de
billets mais qui répondent toujours
présent donc voilà tout ça tout ça est
de bonne augure et présage à nouveau
d'une saison culturelle
très riche comme vous le disiez mais
bien remplie également au niveau des
salles alors on va parler de la
programmation en théâtre et plus
particulièrement en comédie vous
proposez la pièce l'embarras du choix je
vous propose de regarder un extrait et
on en discute juste après alors comment
je m'habille pour le rendez-vous le
vieux cuir un peu rock ou la veste en
velours simple mais classe il faut que
tu me donnes le bon conseil qu'est-ce
que tu ferais toi c'est marrant tu as la
même vitesse que mon grand-père merci
tous tes amis sont là
[Musique]
de mensonges et de l'acheter
alors une pièce qui s'annonce comique et
où aussi là le public pourra interagir
avec les acteurs sur scène puisqu'ils
vont écrire la suite de l'histoire c'est
en ça qu'elle est très originale parce
que
bon pour l'avoir découverte cette pièce
là c'est vrai que les deux trois
premières minutes nous plonge dans un
univers un peu votre village qu'on a
tendance à se dire bah ça va être
quelque chose un peu classique mais en
fait ça bascule très très vite on a ici
une pièce qui propose alors qui est très
interactive avec des comédiens qui sont
magnifiques puisque non seulement ils
ont un talent de comédiens
improvisation mais ils ont aussi un
talent de stand-up ce qui n'est pas
donné à tout le monde ils interagissent
avec le public avec
9 versions différentes en fonction du
choix du public et puis au final on se
rend compte que quel que soit le choix
du public
les choses ne vont pas aller si bien que
ça donc c'est vraiment un grand moment
de rire avec des comédiens qui voilà qui
réagissent aux réactions du public un
public qui réagit au
jeu des comédiens tout ça nous plonge
dans un univers pendant une heure et
demie assez incroyable et vraiment très
très originale alors autre pièce ou
j'ose dire cabaret que vous proposez
c'est le Cabaret des frissons garantis
le public aura le droit à des tours de
magie des tours de cirque ou encore des
chansons là aussi je vous propose de
regarder un extrait on en parle juste
après
la moutarde et le beurre la mayonnaise
était les cornichons
le poulet l'hélicoptes les eaux durs et
puis les cornichons pour faire ce tour
j'ai besoin d'une bonne table un verre
une bouteille et de tube je vais faire
passer le vert à la place de la
bouteille et la bouteille à la place du
verre
et moi le travail si vous voulez qu'on
boit un coup ensemble il faut deux
verres
et de bouteilles
à la petite soif à la grande foire
ça s'annonce déjantés cette pièce
c'est un cabaret déjanté mais c'est une
on est très attaché et puis surtout ravi
de programmer cette pièce là parce que
elle est un peu particulière cette pièce
elle rentre dans le cadre de politique
d'inclusion
[Musique]
des personnes en situation de handicapés
un attachement vraiment très particulier
au niveau de la ville en termes
d'inclusion on développe tout un tas de
choses dans les différents secteurs là
on a affaire à une compagnie qui est la
compagnie du Théâtre de cristal qui en
fait à partir de 2004
en partenariat avec l'association harpe
c'est à dire handicaps autisme
association réunies du Parisi a
accueilli 15 artistes de façon pérenne
pour les former à tous les arts de la
scène et ici on a le résultat absolument
bluffant où je vous défie d'abord de
constater quoi que ce soit au niveau du
handicap et c'est bien là le combat que
l'on mène parce qu'on parle d'inclusion
mais il faut il faut quand même faire en
sorte que à un moment donné tout ça
rentre dans les normes et que on est
plus besoin d'évoquer l'inclusion et que
tout le monde puisse y a des talents
dans tous les secteurs il y a des
talents chez toutes les personnes et ici
on a affaire à une quinzaine de
comédiens qui sont absolument talentueux
alors toujours dans le domaine du
théâtre je vous propose de parler d'une
pièce un peu plus sérieuse je ne cours
pas je vole dans cette pièce la metteur
en scène a décidé de revenir de raconter
l'histoire d'athlètes de haut niveau
exactement alors là encore une fois une
prestation époustouflante puisqu'on a 23
personnages qui vont être interprétés
par interprété par six comédiens
différents c'est une pièce qui a été
labellisée Olympiades culturelle
voilà avec une Olympiques qui se
dérouleront bientôt sur le territoire de
50 ans
vous doutez bien donc euh oui oui parce
que c'est une programmation qui est
prévue en février donc on a plusieurs
plusieurs événements à venir qui
préparent en quelque sorte le public à
ce grand moment que vont être légitier
au p2024 sur notre territoire non pas en
France mais sur notre territoire tout
particulièrement et c'est vrai que cette
pièce là qui a reçu 5 nominations au
Molière mérite d'être vu ne serait-ce
que pour la prestation scénique
absolument époustouflante de l'ensemble
de ces comédiens alors au programme
également José Cachin de la musique bien
évidemment vous allez recevoir notamment
Ben l'Oncle Soul et trois cafés
gourmands oui
oui bah écoutez Ben l'Oncle Soul qui qui
nous présente un concert suite à la
parution de son dernier album qui est
beaucoup plus intimiste et qui mérite
voilà qui mérite qu'on s'y intéresse de
de plus près donc on l'avait déjà reçu à
la Ferme du Manet il y a quelques années
voilà avec une salle qui était en folie
on a des adeptes on a aussi des gens qui
sont là pour découvrir donc nul doute
que c'est un concert qui rencontrera un
vif à vivre succès et puis trois cafés
gourmands voilà trois cafés gourmands
qui ne connais pas trois cafés gourmands
donc je là c'est un petit peu c'est une
curiosité est-ce que les gens vont bien
répondre à l'appel des trois cafés
gourmands je pense que étant donné la
popularité de de ce trio enfin encore
une fois je me fais pas trop
d'inquiétude quoi justement
[Musique]
tous les pièces de théâtre
[Rires]
alors on a aussi Kyle Eastwood qui va
venir se produire sur scène José Cachin
là on est plus sur de la Somme
voilà mais surtout un coup de cœur
iront moi à son père avec un quintet où
il va interpréter un certain nombre de
musiques de films dans lesquelles son
père a eu l'occasion de jouer donc on va
retrouver entre autres bah les grands
les grands standards le bon la brute et
le truand bon je vais vous passer tous
les titres de films mais en tout cas et
c'est la salle Jacques Brel donc on sait
que la salle Jacques Brel est
particulièrement
adéquat pour pour faire des concerts
comme ça un petit peu intimiste et tous
toujours proche du public donc non non
très heureux d'accueillir callistood
très heureux alors bien sûr de l'humour
José Cachin on aura également la
troisième édition de please stand-up
c'est devenu le l'événement
incontournable à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
vous savez on en est particulièrement
enfin presque au stade où quand vous
lancez une programmation comme ça et que
vous annoncez une soirée de l'humour on
a des gens qui se posent plus la
question ça fait partie des places qui
sont vendues le plus rapidement qui
affichent complet très très vite mais là
on fait un plateau 100% féminin 100%
féminin 100% féminin et vous allez aussi
accueillir Paris un autre humoriste qui
est très reconnu sur la scène très
reconnue on a cette chance de pouvoir
l'accueillir également on n'a jamais
accueilli à la Ferme du Manet ça va être
une ça va être une première mais voilà
on a déjà eu beaucoup de gens qui se
sont manifestés pour
savoir très précisément quand la saison
culturelle allait ouvrir ne serait-ce
que pour Paris
vous voyez alors au niveau de la
billetterie on va appeler les dates du
coup à partir du 19 juin pour uniquement
les ini-montins
18h exclusivement réservé aux ini
montains avec un principe qu'on a lancé
l'an dernier le principe des abonnements
donc trois formules d'abonnement
avec quels sont les tarifs environ alors
les trois formules d'abonnement c'est
simple en fait on a l'abonnement
beaucoup c'est à dire trois à cinq
spectacles ce qui permet au final
d'avoir une réduction de 20% sur
l'ensemble des spectacles l'abonnement
passionnément qui va de 6 à 9 spectacles
où là on est sur une réduction totale de
30% et après à la folie on est à 9
spectacles et plus
où là on est sur une réduction totale à
hauteur de 40% l'an dernier on a lancé
cette ces différentes formules on a eu
43% de gens qui ont adhéré à l'ensemble
de ces formules là
14300 et quelques billets qui ont été
vendus au total donc c'est une formule
qui fonctionne bien il y a pas de raison
que on s'arrête sur un si bon chemin
accepté notre invitation si vous
souhaitez réserver vos places du coup
rendez-vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran ce sera
du coup le 19 juin uniquement pour les
inhymontants et à partir du 26 juin pour
tout le monde